the high point of what Iran calls its
sacred defense week the annual military
parade commemorates the country's war
with Iraq but this year it's also a show
of strength to the US and its allies as
Washington orders more troops and
equipment to the region Iran's president
Hassan rouhani is warning them to stay
out of the Gulf alarm Makwana we say
this to the world the presence of
foreign forces may be problematic and
dangerous for the region they may be
dangerous for international waterways
for maritime security for oil and there
may be dangerous for energy security
tensions in the Gulf have spiraled since
the September 14 strikes on major Saudi
oil sites the US and Saudi Arabia have
repeatedly blamed Iran for the attacks
which were claimed by hootie rebels in
Yemen to iran denies involvement but the
Saudis say they'll take action if
evidence shows that Iran was behind the
bombings we are certain that the attacks
did not come from Yemen but north of
Saudi Arabia investigations will prove
that we will release the results to the
world and take necessary measures amid
the escalating rhetoric Iran's military
says it's ready for combat and for any
scenario commanders have threatened a
crushing reaction to any aggressor